hey what's going on is Bill burn it's
time for the Monday morning podcast for
Monday July 16th 2018 what's going on
how are ya how you doing it's Sunday
afternoon when I'm recording this I'm
still in Seattle Washington I've yet to
do by shows up here I'm imagining that
they're gonna go pretty well I was in
Portland Oregon last night Jesus Christ
great shows amazing people coming up you
know even though I teased him a little
bit you know I was making fun of some of
the people in Portland do you know what
I would like what really amazes me about
this generation actually maybe like the
patent I guess the past ten years it's
just the amount of [ __ ] that guys do in
their 20s and that like if I did it back
in my 20s I would get this [ __ ] kicked
out of me it's really unbelievable is it
bill how about an example I'll give me
an example I was coming over from
Portland Airport by the way the first
time I've ever landed here well ever
landed in Portland I should say where it
was actually just sunny and beautiful
like I believe my first aborted landing
I ever had wasn't Portland Oregon was
[ __ ] raining and the guy was coming
in there was all this wind shear and
then he just [ __ ] went up and around
again and we were all like dude what the
[ __ ] I mean this old guy was just like
you know take as many chances as you
need many times as you need like just
get this bucket thing on the ground
everybody kind of left so this was the
first time that was way back when I was
working [ __ ] Happy's it's a comedy
club down the street which is a really
interesting gig cuz the guy who ran it
back in the day you know he would paper
the entire room which means he would
give the show away she going in on
Tuesday and the place would be packed
with people who you know won a comedy
show you know what I mean so was weird
it was like doing this giant office
party and you do one Tuesday one
Wednesday one Thursday to Friday three
and then one on Sunday and but the cool
thing is I got to hang in Portland all
week check out all these cool places to
eat and now I kind of dip in and dip out
but that's that that's an old story so
anyways we're getting back to what the
[ __ ] I saw driving from the airport from
Oregon from Morgan from Portland Airport
over to my [ __ ] hotel I swear to God
I saw two guys in their 20s on a bicycle
built for two
and then behind the guy those two guys
was another guy do you remember those
cars when you were a kid if you had like
a toy car you got it got in it right
he's made all out of metal and then you
peddled it yeah this guy had an adult
version of that car riding behind the
two guys on a bicycle built for two now
this might seem harsh and I might seem
old-school but shouldn't they be getting
this [ __ ] kicked out of them I know in a
perfect world they should be able to do
whatever makes them happy but there's
just something about that behavior where
you're so begging for attention you know
what I mean you just can't get on a
bicycle it's got to be a bicycle built
for two it's got to be a little toy car
and you're a [ __ ] adult in it with
your goddamn hipster beard like I don't
know I'm really disappointed with the
bullies in the millennial generation you
know you're letting a lot of stuff slide
something a [ __ ] spit ball anything I
mean I thought I just I was in the
middle of the pack when I was in school
I got bullied and I bullied some kids
you know I was right in the [ __ ]
middle you know I was background I
wasn't cool I wasn't a nerd I was just
one of those people that filled out your
class picture that's all the [ __ ] I was
you know and I just felt like this
pressure like that somebody is not doing
the job needs to get done
I felt like sticking my head out the
window like [ __ ] ogre in that goddamn
movie and just be like
just something I mean how as an adult
are you supposed to sit there talking to
another adult with a waxed mustache and
never [ __ ] bring it up you know I
don't know that you I don't know it's
it's really is like it's like how bored
are you as a [ __ ] person that you
have to like become like a character
like you go back and you watch a beer
commercial from the late 70s or early
80s and then you just decide that you're
gonna dress like that guy but you're
still gonna be your douchey self but
you're gonna have you know his moustache
and hairdo and t-shirt it's really
[ __ ] weird I don't know I don't know
just the [ __ ] that bothers me I'm having
sort of a anger relapse I was doing so
well and the other day I snapped in the
car when this [ __ ] person just you
know took him like nine tries to
parallel park and if they actually felt
weird to yell in the car cuz I hadn't in
a good three weeks so I tried to get it
in check but I think I let the [ __ ]
genie out of the bottle so I need to sit
down and work on myself again because
today when we were flying from Portland
up to Seattle you know we were boarding
the plane and I was in the first group
you know after people in the military
people with disabilities people with
kids people with dogs that make them
feel like it's okay to fly people with
acne problems like I don't have any
[ __ ] groups there right now before
Group one boards group one is really
like group 26 at this point right
you know it's blue shirt Fridays anybody
with a blue shirt can now board anyway
so we walk out into the tarmac to board
right and I see this woman in front of
me has stopped
you know it's like when he steals what
you walk outside to get on the plane
there's this little zigzag sort of ramp
you have to walk up and she stopped
well this flight attendant is helping
this other woman up there so I'm
thinking in my head well you know if she
didn't tell me to stop so I'm gonna walk
around this lady I was kind of being a
douche and I went to walk around her and
she [ __ ] stuck her hand out like that
she told me to wait she kind of like hit
me with their hand she did like the
mother thing and she was like old like
white hair and [ __ ] and like the [ __ ]
that went through my [ __ ] head not
initially when she hit me I was just
surprised like what the [ __ ] she just
hit me oh my god and the level that I
judged her I was like is that how you
got up in the first class you [ __ ]
competitive [ __ ]
you know meanwhile I was gonna walk
around her and I knew I was supposed to
wait and I was being a douche I just
kept playing it over my head that I just
wish I walked right through her a little
[ __ ] stiff arm that she gave me and I
ended up sitting behind her on the plane
and in my my in my my brains telling me
to hit the back of her chair to rattle
her head a little bit but you know did
the rest of my brains going dude it's an
old woman why are you letting her get to
you like this and then when we landed I
was thinking like she's not married
there's no [ __ ] way any guys putting
up with her and I looked and she had a
wedding ring and I was just like the
[ __ ] is wrong with me some were getting
off the plane I walked down with those
ramps and I was actually laughing at
myself because I knew I was gonna have
to pass her and get into the airport
before her you know just to somehow make
up for that [ __ ] moment right how
[ __ ] stupid is that and then I do it
I turn around implants look at her she
doesn't even know that I exist and I
wasted all of that energy you know it
probably took probably I don't know
forty seconds off my life with that
level of just you know it was like legit
Hey
like I hated this person I mean I don't
like said she should [ __ ] touch me
you know what am i you're supposed to do
you don't owe me so say 8d yell at some
old lady it's your [ __ ] hands off me
lady do it again you'll never bake
another batch of cookies I mean well
what exactly am I supposed to be doing
there I just you know I created that
whole situation and I've really if I'm
honest looking back I knew that she was
flying first class so she was probably
on some level of lunatic and I in a
control freak
and I kind of knew that if I went around
her it was gonna bug her I just did not
anticipate her giving me the flare chop
when I tried to go past her so I kind of
got what I deserved
oh man
I can't believe how upset I let that get
me and I created the whole [ __ ] thing
I really am a pathetic human being but
you know it makes for a good story you
know it helps fill up a podcast sitting
there in the hotel room right oh by the
way so I meant I'm in the airport we
know before this lady gave me the flare
chop and the World Cup final is like
happening and I'm taping it at home and
it is so not a big deal in this Airport
that I can actually walk in public well
the Superbowl of the world is being
played and no one's can there's no
spoiler alert nothing no one had it on
it wasn't on on any TV I didn't see
anybody watching the [ __ ] game on
their phone if I didn't go on Instagram
I wouldn't even know who won it's
[ __ ] insane but anyways I guess
France won all right congratulations
what do they say Leigh Leigh Leigh blue
right now Leila blue congratulations to
France and congratulations to Croatia a
country of what 4.1 million people
according to Pete Davidson in his
Instagram page that they got that
was [ __ ] incredible and I knew I was
gonna be happy with either person
winning and uh I obviously love France
and Croatia was the other dog so I was
rooting for them but I did not see the
game I heard there was an own-goal you
know fortunately he didn't do that in
South America so I think he has a chance
when he gets back to his hometown but
they lost by two goals anyways the [ __ ]
you gonna do but I did not see it but I
did in this world club become a soccer
fan and I've gone from not giving a [ __ ]
to wanting to Google where the next
World Cup is gonna be so I can actually
go and I'll go there with 40 other
Americans if our team makes it and we'll
cheer him on till they lose in the first
[ __ ] round or whatever the [ __ ]
happens
so anyways I'm up here in Seattle
Portland and Seattle we know two of my
favorite cities what are your favorite
cities Oh glad you asked Portland
Seattle
I'd say Seattle over Portland you know
they're both nice Portland just has a
little more of a hipster douche factor
you know it was sort of a tie and then
when I saw that guy in the vises the
tube guys in the bicycle built for two
with the kid with the kiddie car behind
it I said I got my [ __ ] can't alright
you know then come up to Seattle you got
the New World Order hippies I mean
there's a lot up here to kind of be
annoyed with but uh beautiful cities
lush land all kinds of water and so
that's just amazing up here San
Francisco Los Angeles Milwaukee
Minneapolis Chattanooga Tennessee these
are my favorites
[Music]
obviously I'm from Boston uh Cleveland
Detroit Buffalo Pittsburgh I think
that's it the rest of the towns can all
go [ __ ] himself kidding Tulsa Oklahoma
which what's my favorite one in Texas
I'm going there in two weeks I'm going
to [ __ ] Houston Texas in July as a
redheaded bald male the [ __ ] was I
thinking Houston Dallas San Antonio
Austin College Station I don't know it's
they're all kind of the same it's flat
this the most shiniest new pickup trucks
you've ever seen in your life I've never
seen so many shiny brand-new pickup
trucks in my four-door pickup trucks in
my life that look like they just they
just got taken right off the showroom
floor can you hear my stomach growling
by the way I'm having a steak dinner
tonight so I just ate light like an hour
and a half ago I had a soup and a salad
[ __ ] old bastard by the way I'm up to
70 pounds on the lat pulldown machine
now you like that the [ __ ] rotator
cup is rehabbing and person helped me
out told me I need to get up to about
120 pounds on that thing and I have to
do it really slowly so I don't [ __ ]
blow out my shoulder again I forget 120
then I can attempt to do four pull-ups
and I'm back in the game because I have
a bet with virzi that when I'm 70 I'll
be able to do ten of them and that's not
gonna be a [ __ ] problem
that's what I'm saying at 50 we'll see
it's a long 20 years man I'll tell you
all depends on how I do it you know if I
live my life the way I did last month I
won't be able to do two pull-ups I don't
know if I'll be around to do pull-ups if
I live my life the way I'm living at
this month you know I might do 15 I'm
crushing it this month was 16 days in
old freckles hasn't had a drop of booze
said shutting it down
shutting it down for a month give
yourself a good [ __ ] month then ease
myself back into my binge drinking I
can't tell you this though I have never
caught a [ __ ] cold like this cold
that I caught in Minneapolis and into
whatever the [ __ ] I went after that
Detroit Jesus Christ this thing has been
lingering I caught it on like June 30th
and I was sick for a week and now it's
just been lingering like I don't know I
don't need to lay off dairy or something
to get the last little bit out of it
last night I was on stage I started like
cough and my throat was getting all
[ __ ] dry I don't know I'm sure you
guys out there none of whom are doctors
all have a [ __ ] reason why you know
maybe I'm just an old bastard speaking
of that speaking of being an old bastard
I put the TV on in this hotel this hotel
is really [ __ ] annoying like I wanted
to order room service and it's like
where's the menu where's the menu I
can't find the menu so I call them up
they got the menus on the TV so I'm like
okay all right well I'm not gonna get
upset you know I've been getting up too
upset lately let's just this is the way
the kids do it nowadays let's do that
and I go on there right and you know
goddamn well that the [ __ ] thing is
on the TV because it because they want
you to so they want you to order through
the [ __ ] TV so they have that
information what's his name who is he
how old is he what food does he eat
we've gathered all of this [ __ ]
information what kind of porno does he
watch did he rent a movie all of this
[ __ ] information not to mention
they're probably watching you through
that little [ __ ] camera on the TV too
and then they just bundle it all
together and they sell it so I didn't
order through the TV I called instead
that probably got something connected to
the phone it's just [ __ ] like it's
[ __ ] unbelievable
I would can you imagine if you actually
read the file you know on yourself that
these corporations have like
the amount of [ __ ] information that
they have about you and if they actually
kept the video because they've been
they've gotten busted watching people in
the in their [ __ ] houses watching
people in their houses watching TV what
have you banging your wife you know what
if you're walking around [ __ ]
butt-ass naked what do they do with this
how is that legal
it's unfuck in real man
these [ __ ] nerds are making robots
that you can [ __ ] that down they're
[ __ ] them at the factory trying them
out before they sell it to us you got
these other [ __ ] nerds they're in the
goddamn TV watching you're [ __ ] your
wife and there's barely a ripple barely
a [ __ ] ripple but as a comedian if
you send out a [ __ ] tweet that steps
on somebody's toes all of a sudden it's
like this big [ __ ] dust-up if I ever
get in trouble for a [ __ ] tweet or
anything like that's gonna be my defense
hey hey hey hey guys guys guys I'm not
[ __ ] a robot okay I'm not bundling
your information watching you banging
your spouse through your [ __ ] TV
let's have some priorities huh ladies
sorry get no [ __ ] amped up here again
you know alright so anyway so I get it I
put on the TV to try to find the [ __ ]
menu and this TV so like the only way
you can like change the channel is you
have to go back to guide and then go
through I mean I came I can't even
figure out the [ __ ] TV this is why I
hate technology and why I felt like
somewhere in the 90s they just should
have stopped quality of life was good
enough you know but this [ __ ] where it's
just like I always equated to reading
it's like I learned how to read I didn't
have to relearn how to [ __ ] read
every six months but like with computers
and TV and [ __ ] that's what it's like
it's like hey I know how to turn on a TV
I know how to operate a TV and then the
next day oh wait no I don't now I have
to waste time relearning something that
be like every time you got your [ __ ]
car you didn't oven every six months now
you don't know how to drive you have to
learn how to [ __ ] drive again we get
it bill you don't like technology no I
like it I like it to a point you know
central air conditioning you know modern
medicine and that type of [ __ ] but I
mean we were we were all [ __ ] good
right up until then I mean what if they
really cured in the last [ __ ] 20
years people still die of cancer people
still go bald you know you know people
still get hammertoes actually they can
fix hammertoes right stop hammer toes
boo-boo right they can fix those [ __ ]
things can't they anyway so I get into
the [ __ ] hotel here and I saw this
hilarious ad for this [ __ ] called age
ages Ageless Male you know and then like
once you get over the age of 40 your
testosterone levels go down and yeah cuz
you're too old to [ __ ] cuz no one wants
to see you with your shirt off cuz
you're [ __ ] old and now people are
taking these goddamn young pills you
know you want to [ __ ] right into your
80s you want your dick to stand at
attention you want your balls to support
the troops get this [ __ ] Ageless Male
at least [ __ ] morons pumping all this
extra testosterone isn't that how you
loose your [ __ ] hair is there like a
testosterone issue like you have too
much in there that's gonna be [ __ ]
hilarious all these guys going for abs
that had a nice fat of hair then they're
gonna go [ __ ] bald now they got to
get the [ __ ] hair plugs it just never
ends I bet the guys who make hair plugs
also make Ageless Male you know and then
and they've gotten like all the bald
guys that gave a [ __ ] enough to get hair
plugs they've kind of like you know you
reach that saturation point like
remember Crocs
it's just they ran out of douche bags to
find to buy those things which by the
way man I've been like I told you
getting rid of a bunch of [ __ ] and
[Music]
that's all I see stuff as now I just
look at it like that [ __ ] I'm just
to throw out one day you know we walked
through the airport D del Rey who
[ __ ] murdered last night
murder do you hear me murder he was
pointing out some store at the airport
that sells records and all this [ __ ]
he's like manna they do that store kills
you know Dean talks he's [ __ ] kills
man people go in there and I just looked
in there I go that is just a bunch of
[ __ ] I'm gonna have to throw out one day
I'm done dude I'm not taking anything
you know well I did that show like last
week at the hooters upstairs in the big
room when I left they try to give me a
[ __ ] hat and a t-shirt I'm all set
thank you oh good
don't need that laying around the
[ __ ] house I got so many goddamn
jackets I don't know how to [ __ ] I
have enough [ __ ] jackets I could
clothe every homeless person that's
roughly my size in Los Angeles the
amount of jackets I have and does
anybody know is there a coat drive
it's [ __ ] July when's the next coat
derive I'm getting I'm gonna have one
winter coat one [ __ ] spring coat and
then [ __ ] some piece of [ __ ] when it
rains that's it when the [ __ ] that I
become coat guy I can't I don't even I
think I have like [ __ ] 20 coats got
all this sports [ __ ] I'm done with it
I'm done I'm telling you right now I
want to [ __ ] dress like Malcolm young
rest his soul the rest of my life James
and a [ __ ] plain t-shirt you got to
get the plain t-shirt I'll tell you why
even though you didn't ask you don't
have any emotional attachment to it
right if it says the end of Rhonda she
like oh that's where I went on my
honeymoon when I banged my wife up in
the [ __ ] mountains and he can't get
rid of it but if you [ __ ] her in a
plain gray t-shirt you know you know you
know remember that and then you know
what you get rid of it
that's what it's all about this sad bowl
of [ __ ] vegetable soup
that's eh I met now people I'm 50 years
old and I order a soup and a salad and I
eat it and then right afterwards I feel
like I need a nap which is why you need
Ageless Male you don't age naturally die
when you're supposed to and get the [ __ ]
out of the way all right let me let me
read some advertising here for this week
shall we shall we let me recently
advertise new hotel tonight hotel
tonight is the only booking app you need
on your phone what if you want to book
some other [ __ ] I'm gonna book a [ __ ]
stripper for a party I would think you'd
there's an app for that
you know anyways hotel tonight partners
with the top-rated hotels to help them
sell their unsold rooms and passes those
savings along to you which means you get
great deals for four great rooms
unlike other hotel booking sites hotel
tonight tonight do not do now Phil
calling son gonna make it right tonight
tonight you can't tell me someone was in
the studio going like I don't know Phil
I don't think that just sounds annoying
it does not sound like a [ __ ] hit
unlike other hotel bookings Hotel
tonight doesn't there's no [ __ ] way
I'm singing that for the rest of us I
apologize does it doesn't have long
endless lists of a zillion hotel choices
instead hotel two night shows you only
the best deals at the best hotels rooms
are categorized to help you find the
room that's right for you it's like a
top-shelf one okay they're not gonna let
you know that motel six has a [ __ ]
broom closet available for three dollars
for the night that you need another wrap
for that you know that same app you can
probably get a bag of meth to go into
that [ __ ] hotel hips solid basic
luxury luxury get the room you're
looking for
in the right place at the right price in
the 11th hour but it's not just for
last-minute bookings it's perfect for
planners as well as procrastinators I
just realized I'm going to a big I'm
going to the Michigan I think I'm gonna
go to Michigan Wisconsin at the big
house this year I need some hotel rooms
Brow's you're destined desired area with
map view searching and get inspired to
travel perfect for spontaneous weekends
three-day getaways staycations the
greatest vacation you'll ever take road
trips business trips booking a hotel so
you can use the pool etc download the
hotel tonight tonight app toy at now
they kind of ran out of the copier where
do i download it it doesn't say this is
download the hotel tonight app toy at
teo y at and with promo code ber be you
are are you can get the $25 off your
first eligible booking hotel tonight
promo code ber all right that's what it
is
hotel tonight promo code ber hey Hotel
tonight promo code ber staycations the
best but this is what you do you don't
tell anybody you know that you stay at
home you tell everybody you're going
overseas and that your phone isn't gonna
work then you unplug your home phone and
you stay at home you stare at the wall
put on a bathing suit and you [ __ ]
drink a bottle of booze okay
that's living all right oh look who's
back old zip recruiter hiring used to be
hard man multiple job site stacks a
resumes a confusing review process but
today hiring can be easy and you only
have to go to one place to get it done
OHS if dot-com / / zip recruiter sends
your job to over 100 of the web's
leading job boards but they don't stop
there with their powerful matching
technology zip scans thousands of
resumes to find people with the right
experience and invite them
and invites them to apply to your job as
the applications come in zip recruiter
analyzes each one and spots likes the
top candidates so you can never miss a
great match zip it's so effective that
80% of employers who post on zip for
creative get a quality candidate through
their through their site within the
first day with results like that it's no
wonder zip is the highest rated hiring
site in America and right now my
listeners can't ride zip yeah never free
at the exclusive web address zip
recruiter comm / / that zip recruited
comm / / one more times zip dot-com / /
typically the smartest way to hire oh
look who's here but do me on DS me on DS
look at you're a [ __ ] dick doo doo
doo doo me on DS me undies it's hanging
down nice and quick wouldn't it be nice
if you had some more balls get some
testosterone and [ __ ] at the mall
ageless male and some colorful underwear
and then you [ __ ] back in the game as
a World War two veteran you've
definitely heard me talk about me undies
you know the fun comfy undies that feel
as good as they look to those of you who
haven't tried them yet listen up you can
get incredible underwear sent to your
door with me undies meaning no more
hunting around for the perfect pair at a
crowded store and eventually setting
settling for good enough the undies are
made with a sustainably sourced material
from beechwood trees this underwear is
made out of wood evidently and somehow
it's still nice against your balls
they're naturally soft fiber makes a
fabric that won't sag down or ride up
unless your balls hang low okay you
can't blame the underwear that's your
junk trust me once you point on a pair
you'll get feel free to improvise here
about what you love about me undies oh I
love the colorful way my nuts glow when
I walk across
with a pair of me undies and if you're
already part of the undies family tell
your friends about it through their
referral program they'll get you a
discount and you'll get a store credit
it's a win-win still not sure it well me
undies has a deal for my listeners
first-time purchases purchasers can get
50% off their first pair of munities and
free shipping that's 15% off plus free
shipping and a guarantee that you and
your me undies will be happy together I
can't see me jerking off in other
underwear except this me undies get your
butt over to me undies calm and treat
yourself to get 15% off your first pair
free shipping in a hundred cents
satisfaction guarantee go to me undies
dot-com / / that's me at ease calm / /
Jesus Christ there's still two more
let's get let's give you guys a break
for me reading out loud then we'll go to
our first question here okay Eastern
European tour good afternoon
on the July 9th 2018 podcast and around
28 and a half minutes in bill briefly
mentions in Eastern European tour I was
trying to locate specifics on this and
wasn't able to to do so do you have any
information on this or is it just a pipe
dream at this stage thanks no it's a
real [ __ ] tour let's see here I don't
want to name cities alright because I
don't want to get people all you know
thinking that I'm coming and then I
don't let me just see what I can do here
let me find a [ __ ] email why doesn't
why doesn't anything with technology
work for me why can't I get two up to
the [ __ ] search bar here there we go
okay looking for Eastern European tour
Berg European tour
oh no that's the other thing
come on man this was supposed to be easy
man
alright Dollar Shave Club Press
itinerary no subject is it this one okay
these are the ones we were thinking
about doing okay I'm not gonna say him
because I don't want you guys to get all
[ __ ] excited and then I don't go
alright one of them rhymes well this is
a hard one to rhyme with Luda pest
another one rhymes with rock another one
rhymes with Sienna Warsaw aunt
Berlin maybe I'm gonna do Germany maybe
Cologne Slovenia Brussels and I think
we're gonna add some more to that I mean
it's maybe gonna that's it's gonna be in
those areas okay cuz here's a deal dude
if I get close to your [ __ ] country
you know just jump on a [ __ ] train
and go over once your papers please you
know I mean how [ __ ] far am I
supposed to travel you [ __ ] we'll see
we'll work it out but I mean I want to
do more dates than that so we'll see and
this guy interestingly left says Poland
wants you dear bill my husband and I
have been fans for many years we love
the podcast and of course your specials
and all the hilarious and creative
content that all things comedy is
putting out great stuff look at this all
things comedy appealing to people around
the world world world world that's why
we're crazy excited about your upcoming
Eastern European tour we live in Europe
Germany and Poland and think you should
consider Warsaw Poland as one of your
stops there's a pretty lively
english-language stand-up comedy scene
here I love it check out worldwide
comedy facebook.com slash worldwide
comedy and twitter.com slash
whatever the [ __ ] that is something
about Warsaw for some information the
food beer and vodka are great ah you had
me at beer and vodka you'll see the
scars of World War two and Soviet
occupation all over the place for
example on the city streets and highways
driving can be a serious hazard a
driving with bills special edition
episode would be really funny I could
possibly do that for some reason they
wrote WRO like roar claw is a great
University I thought they spoiled Warsaw
wrong roar claw is a great university
city with an awesome history which we
know interests you it used to be called
Breslau and it was one of the nazis
strongholds at the end of World War two
you can Google FET song breasts law or
siege of Brest la for some of the insane
backstory I will definitely be doing
that in fact the Nazis evacuated the
city as the Allies were approaching they
evacuated the citizens to Dresden
Germany where they were mostly all
killed in allied fire bombing yeah and
Dresden yeah oh yeah yeah whoever lost
World War 2 was going to be tried for
war crimes there was all kinds of evil
done in that also this is one of the
cities where the Solidarity movement
started in 1980 which contributed to the
collapse of communism oh I remember that
guy the guy with the big mustache he got
you guys all mobilized over that forget
the guys name plus there are like 400
dwarf statues hidden all around the city
weird but cool anyways we hope you'll
consider adding Poland to your Eastern
European tour we wish you the best
thanks for the great content you and the
ATC network are putting out we love it
PS your name and polish would be either
bill hick or Volusia [ __ ] I can I can
eat with just by those names alone I can
hear the [ __ ] weight that I'm gonna
[ __ ] be putting on when I go over
there I can't wait to do it I've never
been there you know I'm gonna talk to my
[Music]
to my agent again on Monday about this
[ __ ] I mean I might as well do as many
as I can when the [ __ ] am I ever gonna
be back all right and so he's a deal I'm
gonna go over there and all I need is
you [ __ ] better show up all right
because I don't be over there eating
some [ __ ] bratwurst and [ __ ]
Poland in front of three goddamn people
going we were the ones that sent the
emails nobody else gave a [ __ ]
all right LegalZoom everybody becoming a
successful business owner it doesn't
just happen takes hard work goddamn it
you hear that ladies with all your [ __ ]
moaning and complaining about how easy
guys have it even LegalZoom knows you
got to work hard I don't give a [ __ ]
what's between your legs so quit your
crying strap that bra on and get to work
and you really can't afford to let
anything get in your way so when it
comes to all the details and regulations
you need someone that has your back that
someone is legalzoom.com LegalZoom was
created 17 [ __ ] years ago their
mission is to help all Americans
confident confidently and completely
navigate the legal system since then
over a million people have trusted
LegalZoom for business information but
your relationship with LegalZoom hardly
ends there they put together a network
of independent attorneys licensed in
every state available to answer your
questions and provide legal advice for
your business without billing by the
hour since legal zooms not a law firm
because as a business owner you have
enough to worry about without getting
bogged down with the legal stuff man for
that there's legalzoom.com go to
legalzoom.com now and use the promo code
bar at checkout for special savings
Legal Zoom where life meets legal
legalzoom.com and lastly but not leastly
movement watches MV MT you guys have
heard me talk about movement you know
those two college dropouts that started
their own watch company movement watches
start at just 95 bucks at a department
store you're looking at four to five
hundred bucks movement figured out that
by selling online they were able to cut
out the middleman and retail markup
providing the best possible price
classic design quality construction in
style minimalism minimalism movement
watches are all about looking good and
keeping it simple man movement watches
don't tell you how many steps you've
taken or blow your wrist up with text
messages parentheses you up
it tells to that's probably the worst
example they could have done because
that sounds like you're gonna get laid
it's time and it looks good doing it
tells time it looks good doing it if
relevant talk about how smart watches is
overly intrusive on life with
notifications text messages email etc oh
yeah I mean you already have it on your
phone right I don't it's like redundant
it's a hat on a hat as they say in the
writers room get 15% off today with free
shipping and free returns by going to
woven calm MVM tea calm / / C white
movement keeps growing check out their
expanding collection go to M the M T
dot-com / / join the goddamn movement I
was actually gonna order a movie and
then the hotel room here and for
whatever [ __ ] reason they want $24.99
Seca's nobody's going to the movies
anymore so they're trying to make back
the [ __ ] budget of the movie I
actually worked on a movie this week
written by and directed by the one and
only Steve Byrne he got me a couple days
on his movie an old freckles went down
there and I played a [ __ ] so it wasn't
much of a stretch I wasn't really acting
I just sort of did what the [ __ ] I
normally do
anyway she want the great thing about
not drinking is aside waking up fresh as
a goddamn Daisy I mean my freckles glow
when I wake up when I'm not drinking is
I got on the plane and I landed and I
went down and I worked out and then took
a [ __ ] steam and I'm knocking out my
podcast here I would not have done this
granted I don't have any crazy stories
about going into bars and [ __ ] which
kind of feeds the podcast you know but
at some point I just have to make a
decision here you know am I gonna wake
up sober with a less funny podcast or am
I gonna keep boozing and continue to
crush the podcast game no kidding
I actually have no idea where my podcast
is in the overall these [ __ ] people
that do podcast like I'm the number one
[ __ ] bit baby like everybody's
[ __ ] number one everybody has a
million [ __ ] downloads I you know I
want to get it how can everybody be
number one everybody's in the [ __ ]
top ten then I had this guy on as a
guest and it put me in the top ten I'm
[ __ ] like that um anyways what the
[ __ ] was I just looking up I wanna look
up that [ __ ] about the [ __ ] Nazis
dude World War two the the [ __ ]
crimes against this [ __ ] that you read
like this [ __ ] that American troops - I
read this [ __ ] thing in this this guy
shot this Japanese soldier in like eek
the guy couldn't like [ __ ] move I
don't he's like paralyzing he had gold
teeth and the dude was still alive and
the [ __ ] guy took a knife out was
digging the gold teeth out of the guy's
mouth while he was alive and the dude
was screaming in agony the other another
American soldier went up and just shot
the guy like Jesus Christ put him out of
his [ __ ] misery crazy you know what I
mean but everybody makes movies and
everybody on one side he's [ __ ] evil
and everybody else dude you can't you
can't be involved in that [ __ ] with the
people go [ __ ] nuts
you know especially all it is it's just
I would think that once like look how
mad I got at that [ __ ] old lady who
gave me the flare chop now imagine what
if I was man enough to join the armed
services right Armed Forces whatever the
[ __ ] you call them and I'm out there on
patrol and I see one of my friends get
killed like what kind of [ __ ] mood he
gonna be in after that you know it's
[ __ ] insane and then I swear to God
the more I watch the Discovery Channel
and the more I watched chimpanzees
behavior I swear to god just watch those
[ __ ] watch what the [ __ ] they do to
each other watch what they do to other
monkey's and [ __ ] I'm telling you
telling you this it's what that's what
we are whenever i watch [ __ ] on TV I'm I
put send these four years I just always
think of this [ __ ] documentary that
watching these chimpanzees and like 10
of them ganged up on this other chimp
they [ __ ] [ __ ] this thing up did
orrible thinks agonizing things of this
monkey killed it then afterwards they
were all [ __ ] amped up and it was
like they were all talking [ __ ] about
what they did in the fight so whatever I
watched [ __ ] on TV and I see like no
Trump talk in this [ __ ] or that fat [ __ ]
over there in Korea running his [ __ ]
I swear to god he looks like a giant
piece of [ __ ] every Toro sushi it's
like from the softest part of the tuna
like melts in your mouth like god help
that guy if he's ever in a plane crash
that lands in a snowy mountain and they
got to start eating people because that
guy is gonna be a prime cut it's all
[ __ ] marbled you know he's the boss's
son he's never done [ __ ] you know isn't
it funny that he walks around that army
outfit and he's like fat you know as I'm
going to go to the you know those fat
people that always wear workout clothes
that old joke anyways here we go let's
read another one here Africa a Billy
freckled [ __ ] longtime fan love your
work blah blah blah listen I know you're
planning on touring Eastern Europe next
year we got another one but how about a
tour of South Africa
some point if you and the lovely Nia
ever managed to make your way to this
side of the world please don't hesitate
to contact also always know always want
to know if you are friends with Bryan
Cranston or not due to your time
together on Breaking Bad
thanks so much and go [ __ ] yourself PS
when you're gonna be on Conan again a
lot of questions alright let's start
with Africa I would love to go over
there and I can tell you this right now
there's no way I would go on one of
those [ __ ] safaris in that open car
as those lines walk up looking at you I
know they they they say that like those
lions like they look at the car and the
person all is like one giant thing so
that's why they don't just don't jump up
and just yank somebody off the truck
well one of these days one of those
lions is gonna figure it out and they're
gonna yank somebody off the truck and it
ain't gonna be [ __ ] me I can tell you
that right now
you ever see that [ __ ] video that that
poor woman was Asian family she didn't
want to she was driving through the
safari she didn't want to drive and she
got out and walked around the car and
I'm telling you man this tiger comes in
the frame frame and grabs her and Yanks
like I couldn't yank like a dishrag
out of frame faster than this thing took
this 115 pound woman out of the frame
and then like her son or something
didn't know what to do in this [ __ ]
hero ran over there and then he ended up
getting killed and the other his mom got
like mauled or something that's [ __ ]
brutal [ __ ] brutal so I know you
probably laugh and going Phil you know
we have cities over here it's not just a
bunch of lions and tigers [ __ ]
walking around I know but I'm just
saying the touristy thing to go go over
there you're you basically you're Zoo is
the jungle unless I'm crazy I don't know
anyways what was the other thing I
always want to know if you are friends
with Brian Craig I'm friendly with him a
few times I have run into him have I run
into him since Breaking Bad I don't
think I have during Breaking Bad I ran
into him
at a party with a mutual friend yeah and
I don't remember ever I don't ever
remember us coming to blows so I would
say that we are very friendly but we we
don't hang if that's what your question
is what am I gonna be on Conan again I
don't know hopefully soon
I [ __ ] love Conan I love South Africa
and I love Bryan Cranston I mean you
went three for three here
alright the crazies the crazies hey Bill
the crazy little thing about you getting
called a Republican douche is that I see
just as many people on Reddit and
Twitter accusing you of being a liberal
softie yes and all of that is is is just
more evidence of what a [ __ ] I am
alright when I'm in LA I make fun of
Hillary when I'm in a red state I make
fun of Trump you know I don't understand
being in front of a group of people and
just saying what they already think like
where is the fun in that say the
opposite of what they think and make
them mad and see if he can get him to
stay right anyways it seems like people
just attack and focus on only one thing
they care about as you always say as you
always say I love you congrats on royal
Emma Hall it's my dream to play trumpet
there thanks and go [ __ ] yourself well I
hope that dream comes true yeah yeah
I've been accused of it all depends on
what the argument is yeah I think yeah
I've been called yeah a red pill eating
Republican I've been called a liberal
liberal charred snowflake cuckold all of
that [ __ ] and I've been called a
centrist I love the centrist one like
isn't that the smart one well you kind
of in the middle you lean a little bit I
lean left I think I do anyway still all
depends on who the [ __ ] I'm talking to
depends on how far left you are
um how far right you are you probably
think I lean way left I don't know but
uh centrist is somebody like I don't
know I can be swayed you know you
present a good [ __ ] argument you know
take a guy like Ted Nugent I don't agree
with a lot of this [ __ ] that that guy
says but he does say [ __ ] on occasion
I'm like that I agree with
I just don't write people off on a
percent you know and I also don't think
that I have all the [ __ ] answers so
if that makes me I don't know what the
[ __ ] that makes me he says centrist do
you realize how [ __ ] douchey that is
that adults literally have to leg you
come up with and label everything what
that really means is you don't think the
way I think and I can't [ __ ] handle
it so I'm gonna come up with a word that
is gonna have some sort of negative
connotation and I think you're so weak
as a person that it will offend the [ __ ]
with you and I really don't give a [ __ ]
you're a centrist am i okay all right
you're a liberal snowflake yeah okay all
right you're a trump supporter [ __ ] can
i fine fight there you go now go yell
about that to somebody at work anyways
documentary about origin of soccer oh by
the way I learned more about that World
Cup trophy somebody sent me this thing
on Twitter okay so there's one World Cup
trophy and you're not allowed to have it
because it's worth like 20 million bucks
so if you win it you they actually give
you a replica of it this is what this
person was trying to tell me I don't
know if any of this is true then
somebody else told me that if you win
like three of them you actually get to
keep the [ __ ] thing in Brazil gasps
one and then they had to make another
one now rather than just telling you
guys [ __ ] that I've heard I could
actually look up World Cup trophy which
I can't believe how small it is
it's ridiculous World Cup trophy history
here we go all right and I'm gonna click
on let me do what everybody does when
you search something on the [ __ ]
Internet is you just take the first what
the [ __ ] is this thing where the hell
did this just take me
have you noticed now like it just gives
you one option you know they're paying
people are paying for that look at this
it keeps taking me the same [ __ ] site
World Cup trophy history search Google
come on it keeps taking me this [ __ ]
website I'm not gonna name the name of
it look at that it just [ __ ] kicked
me off you [ __ ] [ __ ] how much did
they pay I can only go to you World Cup
trophy Ana triple trophy history search
Google there we go alright that was a
[ __ ] glitch or something the World
Cup is a gold trophy oh it's actually
made out of gold
ours is fake [ __ ] no wonders are so big
I think the Stanley Cup is made out of
[ __ ] aluminium stainless steel maybe
it's a gold trophy that is awarded to
the winners of the - World Cup
associated pop of a but since the advent
of the World Cup in 1932 trophies have
been used the Jules Rimet trophy from
1930 to 1970 and the FIFA World Cup
trophy from 1974 to present day the
first trophy and it originally named
victory but later renamed in honor of
fight for president Jules Rimet or is
that use remot I have no idea was made
of gold-plated sterling silver and lapis
lazuli whatever the [ __ ] that is as
depicted
and depicted Nike the the Greek goddess
of victory
oh is that what the sneaker company has
I didn't know that wait let's do a quick
little aside here in ancient Greek
mythology Naik was a goddess who
personified victory her Roman equivalent
was Victoria she was variously described
as the daughter of the Titan upon the
gods Ventura sisters uh I had no idea I
had no [ __ ] idea
look at that learning something every
even bill can learn something
anyways Brazil won the trophy outright
in 1970 prompting the commissioning of
the replacement well why did it how did
they win it outright they just wanted so
many times like guys give to these
[ __ ] I'm sick of karting it across
the world
the original Jules Rimet trophy was
stolen in 1983 and never recovered
what there's only one / that's a drug
lord something [ __ ] pablo escobar had
that or something
the subsequent trophy called the fight
for World Cup trophy was introduced in
1974 made of eighteen karat gold with a
something bassist an okay now wait a
second wait a second World Cup trophy
stolen maybe wasn't so [ __ ] small
they could have stuck it under this
shirt the theft of the Jules Rimet
trophy it was stolen in 1966 prior to
the 1966 World Cup the trophy was later
recovered one man I thought they said
they didn't get it
one man Steve Brooke of Bristol was
convicted for being involved but other
possible culprits are still in know you
can't tell me that guy's not a [ __ ]
legend trophy placed and how come that
hasn't been made into a movie some sort
of [ __ ] comedy was he some jerk-off
from a sports bar the football
Associated received the cylinder the
theft on the March 20th Sunday March 20
when the guards began a noon circuit
around 12:20 they
notice that someone had forced open the
display case and the rear doors of the
building and stolen the trophy the
wooden bar that held the trophy that
held the door closed was lying on the
floor that's all they had to stop him
these removed the screws and the bolts
that held the other side of the door
they went to Home Depot about some
screwdrivers and stole the biggest
sports trophy in the [ __ ] world what
a simple time they had removed the
padlock from the back of the display
case taking the trophy and left the way
they came none of the guards had seen or
heard anything suspicious though one of
them reported that he had seen a strange
man by the public telephone when he had
visited the lavatory on the first floor
Jesus those guys were [ __ ] off huh
Scotland Yard took control of the case
and gave it to the Flying Squad the
Flying Squad what what the [ __ ] is that
sounds like a musical the Flying Squad
also known as the robbery squad is a
bunch as a branch of this the serious
and organised crime command did an 8
year old named all this [ __ ] with
London's Metropolitan Police Roy is this
serious it's not the it's not the
frivolous Crime Command this is the
serious and organised crime squads
purpose is to investigate commercial
armed and unarmed robberies along with
the prevention investigated 11 gives a
[ __ ] sounds like they have uniforms well
then somebody of that somebody actually
they ransom for the [ __ ] thing
on March 21st Joe Mears the chairman of
the football surgeon received an
anonymous phone call yellow man said
that Mears would receive a parcel at
Chelsea Football Club the next day the
parcel was livid Amir's home it
contained the removable lining from the
top of the trophy and a ransom note that
demanded 15,000 pounds in one dollar one
in five-pound notes the letter stated
that the FA the FAA should place a code
coated ad blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah despite the warnings that Mears
contacted the police detective Charles
buggy of the Flying Squad and gave the
trophy lining in the letter to him
police told Mears to place an ad and
contacted a bank created a false ransom
payment out of bundles of ordinary paper
with real money only at the top and the
bottom which were placed in a suitcase
two police officers were to act as Mears
assistants and handing over the money
and went home two though okay so Mears
was suffering from an asthma attack so
his wife answered instead and gave the
phone to assistant McPhee Oh McPhee
Jackson was nervous but finally agreed
to arrange a switch and told McPhee to
come to all you [ __ ] [ __ ] and then
he got caught isn't that something you
see that you learn something every
goddamn day don't you
what a [ __ ] dope he should just kept
the goddamn thing but he can't what he
gonna show your friends they're gonna
[ __ ] open their mouth trying to get
laid alright anyways documentary about
the origin of soccer hey Bill you're
talking about the origin of soccer last
podcast and London I want to give you a
recommendation to watch wild in the
streets
it's your the origin of all football
including rugby soccer and your football
it is littered literally a type of rug
Lee played by an entire town North
versus South the entire city is the
field they play on well worth the watch
especially for sports fan I found it on
Amazon fire TV have a good
day all right I'll try to check that out
lastly but not leastly classic movies
dear Billy dollars after you talked
about LeMans last month I decided to
watch the movie I really loved it I
never knew I needed to drive through
Europe till I saw that movie I'm 22 and
the first thing I noticed was how
differently
it was paced compared to the
schizophrenic stuff I grew up with it
was very calming in a way I was
wondering if you could recommend any
good movies from that era I'm going to
keep watching between movies but I was
hoping you could give more titles from
the era so I don't burn out all of all
of his at once you can't go wrong with
Steve McQueen you can't go wrong with
Paul Newman obviously Paul Newman you
got it I would watch The Hustler I liked
HUD what else Cool Hand Luke Steve
McQueen you got a an Yul Brenner you
gotta go Magnificent Seven Cincinnati
kid bullet and for those of you before
you go see The Rock movie go watch the
towering inferno if you watch the
towering inferno and then you watch die
hard I think you'll see those two are
combined when they sold that movie
that's the new Rock movie is I feel like
it's those two movies combined wow I
haven't thought about movies in a minute
what else that I like from back then I
liked all the Clint Eastwood spaghetti
westerns love Charles Bronson anything
with Lee Marvin and the Dirty Dozen
bridge on the river kwai Kelly's heroes
[Music]
the Great Escape speaking of which do
you know when I did Steve Byrnes movie
the character that I'm playing at one
point is putting golf balls in his
office and somebody connected with the
movie was friends with the James Garner
estate speaking of the Great Escape and
the putter I used was James Garner's old
putter and I was [ __ ] unbelievable
because you know I always watch me TV
and the Rockford Files is one of my
favorite shows of all time and I loved
it even more than I did when I was a kid
because I never understood
like I think losers too harsh a word but
like how much this guy was struggling in
life he lived in on a trailer on the
beach he had the Firebird he didn't have
the money for the Trans Am and he
couldn't sustain a relationship I mean
the guy was a mess he didn't like to
fight I mean he was just [ __ ] funny as
hell that's another one that I love but
I am right now I'm just burning through
that 77 Sunset Strip with Efrem
Zimbalist jr. I just can't get enough of
that show and it's just it's that
classic [ __ ] lore anytime a woman comes
on screen they play that [ __ ]
saxophone music man it's his [ __ ]
Alerus Ephraim smoking and like every
other scene and in his drink is he likes
an old-fashioned rye and like back then
when they were building a character like
they had to have their drink and they
had to have a car and Efrem Zimbalist
his character in 77 Sunset Strip is he
favors a Ford Thunderbird convertible
and I even want I've only seen season
six so I think that was a 1963 or a 64
Thunderbird convertible but I went
online and I watched the intro to all
the different seasons in
he seems to have late-50s ones because
it ran from like 57 is 63 was like six
seasons or something like that so it'd
be cool I'm watching it and he gets a
new Thunderbird every year convertible
and once again the restaurant the this
office that he's coming out of is Dean
Martin's Dino's that old restaurant that
he had and which was on La Cienega it
was on Sunset Boulevard at the corner of
La Cienega on the southwest side of the
street pretty [ __ ] badass
anyways I'm an old man and I got two
shows to do here thank you to everybody
that came out to Portland last night I
had such great shows and thank you to
everybody who's coming out to my shows
tonight in Seattle this is one of my
favorite cities and I think the next
time I come here I'm gonna try to do
like what I did was in San Francisco I'm
gonna play a smaller venue and just be
here for a weekend I'm gonna bring my
wife and kid up here cuz the lovely Nia
always wanted to go to Seattle and I've
never brought her up here and I don't
know it's a shame because it's so
[ __ ] close and it just never seems to
work out with their schedule so I think
next time I might do one of my favorite
theaters in the country which is the
more theater which view rock fans
that's where Allison change shot that
black and white concert film that's
where Pearl Jam shot that video you know
Eddie better climbed up the side and
drop down into the ground when I get to
down WAMP a couple but the Bam Bam put
it down right minute son alright that's
it go [ __ ] yourselves
congratulations to France went in the
World Cup congratulations to Croatia
England Belgium all you guys that got
down to the final four it's [ __ ]
incredible is incredible thing to watch
and I hope to go the next time there's a
World Cup I'll check in on you on
Thursday
see